foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them
[Music]
it's a very simple question
foreign
[Music]
the laptop from hell
or do they give more of a about
jobs hmm I wonder I wonder I just wonder
if the Republicans have got the memo
that this morning when the jobs report
came out
it's a record of 50 years
of Full Employment it's a record number
a record number
crushing the expectation
crushing the expectation regardless of
what they make up about
inflation and gas prices and gas stoves
and M M's and laptops and top secret
documents hidden in a Corvette no matter
what they make up
there is one thing that they cannot run
away from
the American economy is strong
now does it have its issues absolutely
do we have do we have corporate greed
that is still still putting inflation at
numbers that is ridiculous absolutely
grocery prices and prices that are
affecting America everyday Americans
pockets of course we do
do you expect
the America First Nazi party who is way
more focused on a laptop and Marjorie
Taylor green saying that us Elementary
School in Illinois received five billion
dollars for wokism do you really think
they're serious
do you really think they're serious
about coming up with ways to make this
economy even better no
no the answer is no
absolutely not
Kevin McCarthy goes to um what he thinks
is negotiate with Joe Biden
doesn't bring a budget
and he thinks that he's in a good
position to tell the president United
States what to do
he thinks he's in an excellent position
and then the jobs numbers dropped this
morning even Fox News
had to put the jobs numbers up I mean
they spent as very very few seconds on
these job numbers I mean breezed way
over it
they put them up on the screen I gotta
hand it to them
even they can't ignore the fact
that when Democrats are in control
when Democrats actually are the policy
makers
that we elect to our govern our
government to govern
their economies do well
now can it be better of course it can be
of course it can be but do you think
it's gonna get any better
or do you think it's gonna get worse
with the America First Nazis controlling
the the United States House of
Representatives what's your guess well
we don't have to guess we know
we know what's gonna happen the first
thing they did
was
do political theater to imagineer or get
rid of 87
000 imaginary jobs
you remember this they told this lie
they manufactured this crisis all year
last year during the midterms that there
was going to be almost 90 000 IRS agents
that are going to come to your house
with Badges and guns
and take your money and your Liberty at
gunpoint
because the IRS had hired an army
overnight
of woke of mother wokers with Badges and
guns
it didn't exist it's not a thing there
wasn't 87 000 IRS agents and they passed
a bill to fire all of them
and they thought they were cool because
they passed a bill to fire all of them
even though it's not gonna go anywhere
they think they accomplished something
new
they're sheep
think they accomplished something
the people who still believe them who
are still buying the who
continued to perpetuate American fascism
which is Maga which is trumpism in this
country
speaking of that I have a special guest
today
and we've had him on the show before
he's great friend the show
actor Jeremy London
he joined us I think it was almost a
year ago he joined us
and he talked about politics with us
but he he sent out a tweet
um I think it was a couple weeks ago
about his dad
who was a trump supporter and Jeremy's
going to come on today and tell us the
story because I think I think this is a
significant
um movement that is happening
and it's going to take a long time and
it's little by little we have to chip
away at this
in this country
but to get folks
to admit to their delusion because I
think that's the key here but Jeremy's
going to tell us the story of his dad
who was a trump supporter
in many conversations
being untrumped
I guess you would put it
being untrumps or Jeremy's gonna join us
at the bottom of the hour I'm excited to
have Jeremy also he has um some exciting
news if you guys are Kevin Smith movie
and 90 movies
um
um Fanatics you're gonna like this news
that he has the of a possible sequel so
stay tuned today and you'll see Jeremy
tell us not only about his dad's story
but about a possible sequel
from uh the filmmaker Kevin Smith and
all you 90s movie lovers so hopefully
we'll we'll talk about that a bit when
Jeremy joins us
so these jobs numbers are um fantastic
it's going to be something that is
really going uh to weigh on the House
Republicans
the reason why is because they're not
going to want to address this
the entire reason
that they got elected in their
gerrymandered districts is because they
lied to their constituents that the
economy is and it's horrible
and oh my God your band's destroying the
country
folks we are we are not even 30 days
from them taking 15 votes
to elect the Speaker of the House
Kevin McCarthy having to give away his
entire speakership
to the American first Nazi caucus in the
house
and here we are with job numbers
here we are with job numbers
that are going to bring their narrative
to a screeching halt as long as we do
our jobs
because we have to do our job
in our democracy which is engage in it
it's engaging it now the economic
situation in this country always always
gives
the worst results
to the most challenged
and that should be addressed
and I believe that if we were to have a
congress
especially in the House of
Representatives that was made up of
serious policy makers
that we could address those issues
I believe
the Big Bird build the education bill
that they called Bill back better but it
was an education bill I believe an
education bill could set this country on
the right path
towards success
and to Stave off
future deep recessions now the economy
is going to ebb and flow
but if we had an education bill in this
country
that was comprehensive
paired along with an immigration bill
that was comprehensive in this country
we would see
that corporations would finally
understand why it is worth their wild
and investment
to pay folks
a decent wage
because as we celebrate
these job numbers because I think we
should run laps on this one you know I
don't I don't come here and praise Joe
Biden I barely mention his name
folks I don't need to talk about the
success of serious policy makers
and people who are serious about
delivering for the American people
I don't have to do that
that's not my job
my job is to use narrative and messaging
to protect the American democracy
from people who want to tear it down not
Build It Up
why would I
need to protect our democracy from
people who fundamentally want to build
our democracy up and make it stronger
for the American people
that's what I believe the pro-democracy
Coalition is all about
I believe that it is a big enough
Coalition that we can force fascism in
this country
or as most people would refer to it
trumpism or Maga or as I refer to it the
America First Nazi party to crawl back
underneath their Rock
and today's jobs report is just one
example of what happens when you have a
serious group of people who are really
serious about policy
really serious about the economic
conditions of America
and serious about delivering results for
the American people not corporations not
businesses because Folks at the end of
the day
if the American people
have more equity in the economy
and what I mean by that is making more
money
the majority of people get more of the
GDP it is our GDP by the way just like
this is our government
that gross domestic product does not
belong to those corporations it is built
on our labor
and our Workforce it is ours we do not
we do not have to give it away to them
the greedy corporations that is
and the one percent
that is our GDP
but what happens when you elect a
serious group of people
now you may have your disagreements you
may not meet all the way on all policy
measures you may be frustrated that
they're not as left or as right as you
but when you elect a serious group of
people
who are interested in using our
democracy our governing body
as a way to deliver equity and equality
to the American people
in all shapes and forms not just race
race equity and Equity inequality but
economic
Equity inequality which also plays into
the race Factor
but when you deliver use democracy in a
way serious people
serious policy makers not not social
media influencers
not people who are trying to get famous
like Lauren bobert and Marjorie Taylor
green and Matt Getz and Jim Jordan
people who are interested
in delivering a society
that can be better than it was the the
decade before
and setting it up to where next decade
it can get even better and we can move
towards more equity and inequality
through Liberty and diversity
I believe when you put serious people in
charge over a long period of time
it has a huge difference
in the outcome and the results
and what it means to be free what it
means to be a democracy and what it
means to have Liberty
now I know that the America First Nazi
caucus in the house
of of Representatives right now is only
going to be one of focused on Corvette
documents and laptops
completely understand
I get it they're not serious people
at all
and even if they are they're not even
pretending to be serious
so nothing serious will happen
over the next two years
matter of fact the only serious thing
that they'll do is they're seriously
considering killing our economy by not
increasing the debt ceiling
they will seriously consider destroying
our country by not keeping our
government open and operational their
job that that is their job but
they would they seriously will consider
not doing their job that is how
unserious they are
so as we approach these manufactured
crisis by the America First Nazi caucus
in the house because that is where the
that is where these crises are
manufactured right now
these these manufactured crisis
in the House of Representatives
under the leadership of the America
First Nazi party and Donald Trump
himself
we will begin to see the difference
between serious policy makers
and policy makers who do not give a
about the American people
that is the difference we will see we
also have bonehead of the week today
today's Friday
if you're a new listener here which
welcome welcome to the Tony Michaels
podcast and the em fam speaking of
the fam oh my I want to thank
you so much
for all the new supporters on patreon
what a great what a great feeling it is
that you guys truly support this content
now this content is absolutely free I
broadcast it for free for you to watch
two hours every single weekday Monday
through Friday I will never change that
I don't believe I don't believe I'll
ever change that this show is 100 free
for you to download listen live re-watch
on replays on as many platforms as I
possibly can stream it on
but I so appreciate the support because
you are the best audience in the world
but I so appreciate the support and the
supporters all of you on patreon rather
you're in the 5 10 or 20 dollar tier
the 20 tiers the shout out VIP tier and
I have some shout outs today and I'm I'm
gonna tell you I did a video and it's
being edited
and I'm gonna post it on social media
also
with the shout out on it so all of you
who who are in the shout out VIP tier be
watching for that video on social media
platforms I'll post it across the
platforms I'll post it on patreon first
for you guys to see it and then I'll
post on social media so you can go share
it around whichever social media
platform that you use whether it's
Facebook or or YouTube or or Twitter
Instagram whichever one that you prefer
will post it there but I got some shout
outs here we got Brandon we got Brit we
got Brook the BBB Brandon Brit book
janzy Chris e Margie Midas Robin and MJ
thank you so much and there's your shout
out thank you so much uh for being
supporters of the patreon and continue
to support this show and Independent
Media listen we could not do this we
could not do this without you uh in
Independent Media without your support
um and that's not just it's not just
going to patreon if you want to check
out the patreon just go to patreon.com D
Tony Michaels or go to the Tony
michaels.com and you can check it out
there you can go look at it I I post
some things publicly and some things are
just for the patrons so go check it out
see what you see what you like the
lowest tier is five dollars
and we're going to have some new tiers I
got some new ideas that I want to do for
you guys as the audience
but just come watch come watch come
listen lend your ears lend your eyeballs
to exactly what the America First Nazi
caucus in the House of Representatives
is trying not to do for you as American
citizens because as we get these jobs
numbers today and we watch what happens
when a serious group of people
try to do serious policy for the
American people what the outcome and
results are
we are going to watch in the House of
Representatives over the next two years
with the results of one part of our
government being filled full of
unserious fascist people
that's what we're going to find out
and we are not going to look away here
I'm not going to ignore I have had some
people like oh why are you giving
Marjorie Taylor green a platform why are
you giving these people listen
it's not giving them a platform
they have a platform that in an echo
chamber we're going to talk about it
with Jeremy London and how his dad
finally realized that the echo chamber
was real
and what it took to get him there they
already have their Echo chamber folks
Fox News oan News Max it doesn't matter
if on if it's on DirecTV or not they can
download the app
it's the news Mac Newsmax app is
free it doesn't cost a goddamn thing for
them watch that garbage
so you are we are not platforming them
when we talk about them what we are
doing is exposing them
by giving it correct context in which
their bone-headed lives
and we're gonna do that today also on
bonehead of the week because we got some
great boneheads that we're gonna go
through I don't know if you've seen Gabe
Sanchez is um a tweet but apparently uh
Kyle Rittenhouse
is um a whiny scared little um
which is not surprising not surprising
since you know he's such a cowardice
murderer
um it's not surprising that that would
be what he would do is run away from
being served
for a lawsuit a civil lawsuit that's not
it's not surprising at all
um and also another thing that I hope to
talk about today
um is Kevin McCarthy did you watch this
little clip this is this is
fantastic gold and I I suggest that
anyone out there who is not using this
little clip in the in their threads and
their comments
um everywhere I mean everywhere you see
Ashley Babbitt's name or Ashley
Babbitt's mom or any kind of that
where she was murdered and
she's a hero she's a traitor
she's a traitor
and she was threatening with a mob a
violent mob
of insurrectionist and terrorist
our government's lives our government
officials lives
this is not out of the realm of reality
where people are threatening our
government officials lives where someone
has to use deadly force what do you
think the Secret Service
surrounding the president United States
and the Vice President are for
have you have you lost your mind
have you even watched
the films
of JFK having his head blown off
in Dallas do you understand why in this
country watching Bobby Kennedy get
killed Martin Luther King Jr do you
understand why Gabby Gifford's getting
shot in the face at a at a grocery store
at an event for her campaign
if you want to talk about recent history
Jesus Christ even Steve scalise getting
gunned down by a lunatic on a baseball
field
and you're wondering why we have to
protect
political
members of our government
just recently some Maga Republican
trumped up
rep uh a candidate for State office
New Mexico Pena
firing guns and hiring for other people
to fire guns into people's houses and
you're standing around wondering why
why Ashley Babbitt was shot in the face
get the out of here with this
nonsense
Kevin McCarthy understands it
oh he understands it very well
and the reason why Kevin McCarthy stands
in front of a microphone is the Speaker
of the House
and says no she was not murdered that
force was justified against Ashley
Babbitt the reason why
Kevin McCarthy says that
is because he would want that officer to
use deadly force to protect him
that's why
that's why he says that
I'm sure Kevin McCarthy's life has been
threatened which is really
stupid
that anyone would threaten to kill any
politician
the dumbest thing ever
we can beat them with our ideas folks
we can beat him with our ideas we do not
have to use violence
and when we protest we can do it
peacefully
we do not have to use violence there is
plenty of us
and when you talk about using weapons
and politics the best weapon of all is
the weapon of the ballot
that is what moves democracies forward
that is what sets our democracy apart
and yes you could argue access to the
ballot needs to be more we need to
unjerrymander these districts frankly I
think Democrats need to gerrymander
their own districts them
them you gonna do gerrymandering
you goddamn right we are too in these
blue States box every red
District out every one of them
them
do it you want to play the game we'll
play the game if you if you want to get
serious policy makers
in a situation where we can undo
gerrymandering do you think it's a good
idea to let a bunch of fascists
who only get elected when they
gerrymander districts who only hold
the House of Representatives by a
handful of votes
by electing people like George Santos
because they gerrymander
districts you think they're gonna undo
gerrymandering when that's the only way
they hold even half of one branch of our
government get the out of here with
that nonsense
it is time that we fight with every two
we have but we do not need to use
violence
there is plenty of us
and I don't know if you've seen this
video that I posted there's a new video
we talked about one oh my God this is
I call them yolkaida some people call
them gravy seals but it's this guy and
he's a trumped up white dude in camo and
he's got you know he's got airsoft guns
he looks like a idiot he's got
all kinds of knives and and he's
he's assaulting dummies like literal
mannequins
it's it's really dumb I mean
it's stupid but today the sequel
dropped on Twitter
and um I just can't believe this guy has
not shot himself in the face yet
with these airsoft guns I believe that's
what they are I mean they're so
fake and such frauds that they can't
even use real guns when they're doing
their little I don't know
fascists takeover cosplay I have
no idea what this is it's
hilarious though he in this one video he
hugs a mannequin so I hope I hope and
pray when you maybe we'll get to it in
The Written House part because I believe
if God Rittenhouse doesn't end up
somewhere uh in a cell or something
that's probably what he's going to end
up doing is standing in his yard
shooting Airsoft guns at a bunch of
mannequins so hopefully if we'll
get to that little piece of tape that we
can go to but again I want to tell you
we're gonna have we got a great guest
coming your way at the bottom of the
hour we're almost there
um and we're going to talk about just
speaking of trumpism and talking about
people who believe
the lies we're going to talk about
someone who is Unwound some of those
lies in their dad's mind maybe maybe
change the course and direction of their
dad's life from here on out to see the
light because I don't think that every
single
Trumper
is some sort of hitler-loving fascist I
just believe they've been mind
and we're going to talk about that with
actor Jeremy London when we come right
back don't go anywhere Jeremy London
right after this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Baby It's Cold Outside
everywhere
oh wearing their sweaters on the
beach and
God damn
some videos this morning people ice
skating down their driveways in Texas
ice exists in Texas what let me ask is
is is Cancun crews in Cancun since
there's just a tad bit of ice in Texas I
don't know maybe we should check on Ted
Cruz he's probably in Washington he's
not going to go home he's terrified of
snow and ice
um and everyone's talking about it in
the chat of
how cold it is everywhere it's
cold it's yesterday it wasn't bad
here the day before it was cold
today it's gonna be cold
look I I tried to take my outdoor walks
in the afternoon and this cold weather
is really it up okay
we got to get this under control
Gabe Sanchez joins us actor Jeremy
London joins us fellas
I'm glad to have Jeremy London back on
the show game how about you I'm super
excited I I'm glad because Jeremy
there's a couple things I want to talk
about number one uh Sarah Jeremy London
is
um this story about your dad because you
had tweeted about it
um several weeks ago and I found it
compelling and I was like you got to
come on the show and talk about this and
tell the story but also there might be
some news in a sequel of a Kevin Smith
movie as well that I want to talk about
maybe maybe is his connection off I
think the I think his connection's off
yeah now his connection's off hey Jeremy
why don't you go out and come back in
and see if see if your connection's any
better if you can hear me
um so let me pull up that tweet and I'll
read it as Jeremy gets reset here
um because I think that's that's
relevant to the story of his dad because
Jeremy Jeremy tells the story on Twitter
of his dad
um being a trump supporter
and when he he talks to his dad about it
he finally convinces him see if I can
find it here now he finally convinces
him that hey
you need to rethink this thing this is
the thing that you need to rethink about
this Trump and it probably took many
conversations it wasn't just like one
conversation can you see if you can help
me find that um tweet I guess I should
have pulled it up what a dumbass
what a bonehead speaking of bonehead we
had a great bonehead today oh yeah oh
yeah
we got a great bonehead
um but Jeremy was talking to his dad and
I think his dad was an avid Fox viewer
um and he and he uh
told his dad it was telling his dad and
talking to him asking him questions see
that's the thing about
um some of these people who have lost
their way
is these it's sometimes it's just simple
questions and we talked about it before
Gabe Sanchez where Tucker Carlson does
this same on his show oh yeah two
mind people right right just the
same questions yeah right just the same
way as you can as you can uh here it is
and let's and let's keep in mind that
also Tucker Carlson is someone who has
on on there's literally video evidence
and I can pull it up if we need to or he
says yeah I lie when I'm backed into a
corner I lie he goes I don't want to and
I don't want to do it on television but
I do
that's the person that Tucker Carlson is
outside of you know stochastic terrorism
fueling Fanning the flames and throwing
kerosene on a problem right the same
reason that he is the number one loudest
voice when it comes to any of these
violent terrorists I think you're back
Jeremy
oh no maybe no maybe
yeah it's your connection it's your
connection I don't know if you're on
Wi-Fi or your your cell your cell
connection but one of the others is is
low
um but I'll keep you on if you can if
you can get it adjusted
um I'm just gonna take you off the
screen because I want to show your Tweet
here uh it says oh my God
I just convinced my dad to stop liking
Trump holy I got my dad back
um when I when I read this
I thought wow
and and the thing that struck me about
this um as Jeremy tries to get his
connection back here
um the thing that struck me about this
was that Jeremy's response here was
that he got his dad to stop liking Trump
liking right is the words that he used
but the thing that got me the most is he
said I got my dad back yeah
meaning it felt like his it wasn't his
dad right and I've experienced this with
some of my family members
um as they've kind of got sucked into
some of this quasi-q and on Facebook
um I think maybe Jeremy's back now can
we try now how are we doing now Jeremy
his audio is still oh yeah there it is
maybe maybe well I'll I'll leave you on
screen if you if you talk
I got your Tweet here so
um but Jeremy goes on to tell the story
here
uh and I wanted him to tell it on air if
we can get his audio issues fixed yeah
yeah but he says he made a remark
dodging Biden about the documents so I
lit him up with actual facts now Gabe
Sanchez
this is the other reason why this stood
out to me
um is because it was the documents thing
and me and you had talked about on air
Jeremy how are you now
there we go that feels like it might be
better
perfect Wi-Fi guys is this better that
is perfect we can hear you now we can
hear you now so we were just talking
about um the story here and why don't
you tell the story and then we'll we'll
dive into more of the tweets if you can
I think I think his Wi-Fi is still what
if you here can you can you uh can you
kill your video and just do the audience
yeah just do the audio
um just kill the video and just just
bring in audio and we'll we'll bring you
up a sound and that'll probably work
better because then it won't need as
much of the uh the the bandwidth to do
the video and we can just get your audio
um but you go on to say in this tweet
Jeremy you say it lit him up about facts
about the documents and the documents
um me and me and Gabe talked about this
the moment that Merrick Garland
announced a special counsel
that was going to investigate
the Joe Biden documents right we said
this is not this is not bad
for Joe Biden it's horrible for Trump
and it's horrible for their narrative
more than anything else
is what we is what we said on the show
as it was happening right and this this
conversation that Jeremy had with his
dad only proves that out because what
Jeremy goes on to say is he began to
listen then I educated him on Jack Smith
and the things Trump did to require
desire
but the Clincher was when I enlightened
him that Trump didn't donate his
presidential salary and pay taxes which
we know we would have not known the Ways
and Means Committee did not stick to
their guns and go for his tax returns
and release them at the very end of the
117th Congress Dave Sanchez so if we
would not have received those pieces of
information if Jeremy's dad would not
have received those pieces of
information
he may have not been in a situation
where he could get his dad back which is
a significant phrase in this whole Saga
Jeremy let's let's see we got you now
yeah I still I still don't think we got
you uh hang on
um give us some commentary on this I'm
going to message Jeremy yeah yeah go in
there so yeah I think this is I mean I
think this is huge
um and this probably resonates with a
lot of people right you know like Tony
said there are people in your own family
I've got people in my family uh that are
definitely on the right and definitely
are anti-bitant and pro-trump and you
know everything that Trump does is good
and everything that Biden or the
Democratic party does is bad right the
the demon rats as they call them
um because I've certainly heard that in
my family
but it's important to remember here that
like while the Republican Party itself
it's DNA is is incredibly ingrained in
the idea that their stochastic terrorism
violent terrorists uh you know attacking
LGBT community attacking uh you know
plotting the the the kidnapping of of
Gretchen Whitmer the you know the
Michigan Governor trying to overthrow
the government hiring uh at least four
people to take out Democratic officials
right this is the Republican party right
this is the insanity that's there and so
the idea that
that some people like Jeremy's father
can can take a moment and listen to the
actual facts and the reality of what's
what's out there and not just listen to
Fox News skew and manipulate and distort
like Tucker Carlson or or the five or
Greg Gutfeld or Jesse Waters or any of
those people try to manipulate the
actual facts in reality so that they can
say oh actually it's the Democrats that
are bad and a good example of this as we
saw during the Pelosi attack
for at least a couple months while it
was like still top of mind for the
Republican party they were pushing the
idea that Paul Pelosi had a gay lover it
was a male prostitute it was a big
cover-up all of these different things
right I'm I'm finishing up but what was
that that's covering this and it really
goes through you know Charlie Kirk
talking about how some some Patron in
San Francisco should bail out David de
pal and Tucker Carlson saying it was all
big cover-up
when then the body cam footage is
released the audio interview is released
the audio call in to the KTVU Fox
Newsroom is released about David depap
not only confessing to the crimes that
he did but also saying oh you know what
I actually should have been more
prepared I wanted to harm more people
and that is someone that is not getting
their news from the left that is not
someone who is getting and aligning
themselves with the left that is someone
who is who is uh embracing this hatred
this hate speech this conspiracy driven
uh far right and saying oh yeah it is
Hillary it is the Deep state it is these
demon rats going against people and so
with much of that it's you know you find
people like Jeremy London's dad who at
one point probably believed these things
and it took his own you know it it took
Jeremy the the that moment that
opportunity to say look here are these
things and let's compare them side by
side and then he actually
he actually oh you know opened his eyes
and said holy right and Jeremy
obviously can talk more about that
Jeremy can we hear you now
I feel like this is like a Verizon
Sprint mobile commercial where it's like
can you hear me now can you hear me now
can you hear me now
um I I don't know if I don't know if
we'll get his audio or not I did we did
a sound test with Jeremy uh to be fair
to Jeremy
um Jeremy isn't having internet uh
connect he's not having good internet
connection I don't think to get to the
bandwidth that he needs to to appear on
the show
um so I think he's going around the
house to find the best connection here
with him on his Wi-Fi which I don't
blame him look listen this is not Jeremy
London's fault this is what happens when
you do when you do live actually I would
say that this is it's not Jeremy's fault
you know what I would say I would say
that
that this is the fault of not making
uh fast you know Broadband or you know
even or Fiber Optic internet service a
commodity
of the United States right integrating
into the government right which is which
is what you know you've got the
infrastructure act and other things
where Democrats are like hey we should
introduce this thing to make your life
better we should give you these
subsidies we should give you this tax
credit we should do this we should do
that right or this could be a big
conspiracy where or me and Gabe are just
trying to not let you hear Jeremy London
I mean London the actor from Mall Rats
in seventh heaven and just tease you
with him and then like oh yeah we're
gonna let him tell his story wink and
then you're like oh we're gonna stick
around to hear Jeremy Della's story he
never told his story because Tony and
Gaber right no it's it kind of really
it's just an internet connection thing
and this is what happens with life the
other day I had my audio issues the
audience knows I had my audience my
audio issues the other day
it's really bad wow I don't know what's
going on that was like an AR-15 oh God
Jeremy are you there
you should
this almost feels like right the Matt
Damon Jimmy Kimmel bit where he always
wants to bring him on he goes and we
just finished darn if you want to catch
him we'll get him next time but I'm
gonna go back I want to go back to uh
his his tweet here because
um what he says again he goes on to tell
and he's Jeremy's texting me he says
this is humiliating
no Jeremy it's not listen the other day
I'm the host of the show and I couldn't
get my microphone to work yeah I
couldn't I couldn't do it like in the
lead up to the show and I thought I had
it working and I test it and everything
was cool but then when I went to come on
to the show the thing wouldn't
work like it shut off I don't know what
the hell happened and then Tony texted
me mid-show or like in the beginning I
would come on I was in line trying to
drop something off at the USPS oh
and I get this thing was like hey you
might have to jump I was like my
mic so so I I throw my airpods in and of
course it sounded all right it sounded
all right it sounded all right but it
was not it was not in true fashion let's
try Jeremy one more time I have I have
an alternative it looks like we're gonna
get something Jeremy are you there
okay I have an idea you ready we're
gonna it we're gonna do it live
call Jeremy right now yeah and play him
through your end on the phone
play play okay so that way he can hear
you yeah okay and then we can all hear
him it'll just be through audio Yeah but
it we'll do it live we'll do it
we'll do it live here uh let me see if I
can
if I can get him online here
can you hear it can you hear it ring
uh-huh I can hear it ring oh perfect
this is like we're gonna have a call in
you know there's like a phone line where
people call in Jeremy London is now on
the line Jeremy we just got you on the
microphone
it might be my internet I don't know but
we got you on the line you're you're on
the microphone can you hear him all
right Gabe yeah I can hear him good good
so so Jeremy um here's the thing is that
this is internet stuff right and as Gabe
said if we could get uh people serious
politicians elected that we could get
real internet because you are in a rural
area correct
[Music]
ly
whenever I first moved up here we had
nothing but Fields behind us they're all
turning into effing neighborhoods now
but oh you can say
so so rural internet rule high-speed
internet would be a huge upgrade for not
just you but all those communities that
are being built up around you
so 100 right
you know infrastructure uh is good it
'll uh bettering the country is a good
thing it's what's funny is most of these
like rural communities that
um
that don't understand that right
continue the dog on Joe Biden as if he's
doing like doing anything good for the
country meanwhile the only reason
they're even going to even have internet
at some point whenever they actually get
it is because of infrastructure policies
that are actually taking place and just
getting modern being modernized in
general uh but uh yeah man it really
sucks because I'm on the edge of
basically a bad signal and a good signal
some days it's good here some days it's
absolutely horrible here and it just so
happens that live on the show because
this is what happens when you do things
live and you know this as a performer
100 this is because I think last time we
recorded the interview so it's much
easier to edit out if we had internet
problems right which now we're live do
it live do it live so let me ask you do
it live let me ask you because
um I want you to tell your story and I'm
trying to tell your story here through
your tweets but I want you to tell it
about your dad so tell us
um what was what was how was that in
defining moment was it phone calls were
you in person how did that happen
oh well but the funny thing is is that
my dad's the one that sort of opened the
the um sort of the the Pandora's box if
you will by trying to dog on Joe Biden
about the
documents that were found in his uh
garage and he's like can you believe
that stupid ass Joe Biden the documents
and I'll say wait wait wait hold on wait
a minute what
let's take this back for a second like
what do you and then I said you know
what do you think about
Donald Trump said oh it was only a
couple of hundred things and he'd
probably blah blah blah just started
going in all the talks news talking
points right
and I just was like I cannot believe and
I literally said this I said I can't
believe you were the same man that
raised me
the same common sense
intelligent
actually patriotic because he was in the
Navy human being
that is sitting here trying to tell me
that there is something wrong with uh
Joe Biden
whenever
the world sees what a horrible person
Donald Trump is and so
automatically it just made me
immediately lose every ounce of respect
I've ever had for my father
that is heartbreaking
I never stopped loving him we never
stopped communicating
but I stopped knowing who he was because
my entire life I thought I know who knew
who he was well you know and that that
was the significant part
well that was a significant part in your
tweet that made me pause and I think I
texted texted you as soon as I saw it
because what you had said and I'll I'll
read it again to the audience that said
oh my God I just convinced my dad to
stop liking Trump and then the statement
after was the thing that felt
significant to me because my my wife has
lost some of her relatives and I felt
like I've lost some of my relatives that
I thought I knew like you're saying but
you said holy I got my dad back as
if you lost him if he was gone he was
out La La Land is that how you felt that
you just nailed it I got my dad back
from La La Land I didn't get my dad back
from lack of love the funniest thing is
all these you know immediately the
hateful people come out and they're like
uh if you're you know what a weak person
you are to to to lose your relationship
with your dad and not love your dad
because of politics I'm like first of
all there was never any mention about
love loss it's loss of identity
it's loss of understanding
this man that you always thought you
understood to be
an intelligent uh rational human being
watching him dip into the dark side
knowing full well that he's doing it
only because he's being fed the
information that's causing him to do it
and in so you know it's this is not this
is an evolving thing my dad is not just
you know he hasn't just switched off
overnight but he did
say son I did not realize all this stuff
you know about us just started telling
him all this stuff I tell them the
difference between the the document's
case with the the you know the vice
presidents and then and then Donald
Trump I told him I explained to him all
this other stuff and then he even
brought up you know I even said even
last night he he said said something
about the ice storms coming through
Oklahoma because he lives in Oklahoma uh
and uh we started talking about the the
power grids and Texas shutting down and
my dad
said let me ask you something what's the
deal with the windmills
right not in Texas what and that's
because he's
electricity that the the the load that
uh windmills carries in Texas is so
minuscule that uh these storms do not
shut down the electric grids because of
the windmills they allow the windmills
to be there for a certain that way they
can blame it on the windmills but though
I explained to him the difference in the
you know how uh the Texas electric grid
is separate from the rest of the
national elector grid and that it's you
know to make the world a few wealthy
people uh wealthier there and
everybody else all these people are
dying and their their houses are
freezing and they're they're freezing
um but it's to take a couple of other
people Rich that own these independent
uh corporations that run the electric
grid in Texas and my dad was like wait
what and so
it's information my dad is an
intelligent person
unfortunately he lives in a place where
they're spoon-fed Fox News right
everybody around everybody around him
that's what they talk about and so they
get him worked up
because he doesn't know that he's 70
years old he does
he does win
entertainment
blame to him dad do you understand that
Fox News technically isn't even allowed
to call themselves news I mean what is
Tucker Carlson's defense whenever he
somebody tried to sue him remember he
was like ah people can't take me
seriously I'm just a you know I'm
playing a character whatever that's all
fox is right well that's what I was
going to ask is what that's what I was
going to ask is what what station what
what media and what information he was
actually listening to and it sounds like
Fox News was one of his go-to's yeah
right and it just shows you that Fox
News even not being the most extreme
um out of like right
um you know I mean it is Extreme but
it's not the most of you know some of
the trader TV news networks as I call
them oh and I'm sure and I'm and I'm and
I'm sure and I don't live in Oklahoma
near my dad but I'm sure that once he
started getting his uh his um uh what
did I call it uh okay so my dad you know
my dad thought uh I call it hate math
on you know unfortunately my dad's kind
of one of those sort of old school guys
that you know uh he uh
gets fired up about things like the
Border whenever it doesn't have anything
to do with him he was one of those
people that used to say things that
coming up here and taking our jobs I'm
like
about you you have you working sheet
metal this is there's no that makes you
dude coming up here and taking your
sheet metal job there dad and so it's
it's getting and so and I so basically I
started
talking to him about the things that get
him part of and every without fail none
of it had anything to do with him right
it had to do with all of this other
horse the the CRT and the the
trans-hating and all the things that
absolutely do not affect the the few the
the country in the big picture it's only
these micro things that the Republicans
choose to do it because they don't have
any policies and they don't actually
have any issues and they only are um
catering to one stupid small subset of
human the I don't even I feel that it's
hard to even call them humans they're a
morons that uh
some reason I think that these are the
things that should be um
driving the like I don't know the the
the the world view of what our nation is
well I think you said it I think you
said it correctly because Sue B from
YouTube here says hate hate math needs
to stick I believe I hate Matt this is a
good word for it it's it's the it's the
drug that they use to mind and
delude people in this country to get
them to believe absolute lies
and they need more they need more of it
and whenever they hear something that
goes against that they
glitch they don't even listen to it
because it doesn't feed their narrative
and it doesn't feed their High and as
soon as anything glitches their High
then they shut down and they don't
listen to it and then they get then they
doubled out
well I need
well I'm gonna I'm gonna steal your
phrase hate math
I think that's I think that's exactly
what it is my dad my dad struggled with
meth uh when he was in his 50s for a
brief period of time right got clean all
that stuff but he still has that
mechanism in his brain that that that uh
whatever caused him to dip into that
before he's still there he's only
replacing it with these this this
um this unrecognizable need to just
see them hatefulness right there's
something that drives them there's
something that gives them a charge makes
them feel better then and I can tell you
he's just a fat dude that lives in a
trailer in Oklahoma who has absolutely
no right whatsoever to feel Superior to
anybody else on this planet he is the
epitome of inferior even though it's my
dad and I love him uh he's not the
specimen of health and intelligence that
I used to think he was or that he used
to be right uh you know but he is human
more than anything is in your Tweet when
you said holy I got my dad back I
think that's the one thing that is is
the Hope for our country is that there
it this is a small percentage of people
who um like like you said are on hate
meth it's a small percentage of people
but it's a large number of people in
this country and when they all yell and
scream it seems really loud
um
it's like being enough pepper pep rally
right right
it was it was a high
right well and and so now I want to I
want to quickly
um because I'm I'm running out of time
here at the top of the hour but I want
to talk about because um there's been
some news and you had a few posts on
your social media too about
um a possible sequel now we all know you
were in seventh heaven but one of the
cult classics that you're
um familiar in is Mall Rats the Kevin
Smith movie
um and there's talk that there may be
maybe Mike maybe maybe not
um a possibility of
a sequel is that true
what Kevin told the audience
audience might just be
a smart Castle Theater they had a
screening of Mallrats up there and
people went the list it was so weird
it's just so weird and we shot this
movie 28 years ago and every person in
the audience was literally quoting and
mounting every word in the movie there
was one guy behind me who actually was
getting annoying who literally mouthed
every single said every word in the
entire movie like
it's just weird and so
we've been you know Kevin's been talking
about wanting to do a sequel for this
for a long time in fact we did the whole
you know hold up the two fingers thing
uh literally when my son was about six
months old and he's almost nine
so you know it's it's been a long time
coming in so it's one of those things I
kind of put on my mind and then I went
up there I just got up there and Kevin
said that basically Mall Rats 2 is
reliant on how clerks does
uh I guess it's Warner Brothers I think
the clerics and and um and Kevin tell
the funny story about how well because
Universal Studios owns Mall Rats and so
in order to get to do Mallrats too we
would have to which would be Twilight of
the Mall Rats I believe is what it's
called we would have to get the rights
for Universal and so Kevin went to
Universal but in there you know as Kevin
said he's like guys I'm here let's do
this I'm ready to make a sequel to
Mallrats let's do this and the guy
looked at Kevin Smith and he said
uh we own Mall Rats
the guy was like wait wait Jim was like
I was like this is awesome I love Moretz
and so
that was a positive thing um and so now
Warner Brothers basically has to work
with Universal Studios which isn't
unheard of they've done it you know many
times before to make it happen but Kevin
said that it's looking better than ever
uh clerks 3 is doing great and uh it
sort of was based on that and Kevin you
know told me that you know he has a need
to make this movie like he needs to make
this movie well I I think the country
needs Kevin Smith to make this movie
this series listen hey that would be
cool too
cool yeah maybe Netflix Hulu who knows
where it would appear exactly
it could appear on HBO Max because
doesn't doesn't HBO own uh Warner
Brothers isn't that Warner owns HBO a
Warner Brothers
Yeah well yeah they buy and sell by
himself
but uh hey Jeremy I appreciate you
joining us I got I got one more thing
one more thing before we go we have
someone in the chat that I think you
know personally and it's her birthday
today
um
yeah do you know who I'm talking about
it is it is
it is her birthday and uh after we get
off here when we come back from the
break before bonehead
um maybe maybe I'll do a shot in in uh
celebration of Brandon's birthday but I
wanna I wanted to say that uh
there you go yeah well you can you can
do a shot when we get off the phone not
because I normally do Jaeger and I'm
gonna see if I can get gagged too but I
doubt he went and bought it
iced tea there you go there you go hey
that that sounds good that sounds good
you can pretend that it's hard tea you
know exactly that's good wait Jeremy I I
appreciate you joining us today and and
sorry about the technical difficulties I
know uh
[Laughter]
he'll be able to be able to figure out
what happened today well let's let's
let's do this again well uh come back as
you get more news on uh Mall Rats too
I'd love to hear more news
for your patience yep I apologize no hey
you're you're here you're here that's
the important part even by voice so the
people on the audio podcast will have no
idea I have no idea all right Jeremy
thanks a lot we'll talk to you soon my
friend
everyone that was Jeremy London
um you see here on the screen the
picture of him Jason Lee and and the
director and and filmmaker of Mall Rats
too are Mall Rats accept me in clerks um
the Jade and Silent Bob series he does
play Bob uh in the movie so hopefully
Mall rants too so there's actually uh
there's a it's so funny so before I saw
Jeremy say that he was going to New
Jersey to do this kind of like little uh
watch party with all the fans and Kevin
Smith uh I I came across this I think a
friend sent me this on Tick Tock and it
was a series or I might have just like
stumbled upon but basically it was uh
Kevin Smith answering a question which
was talking about like what's what's
coming up in the next five years
and he he shared that story where he
went to Universal and was like hey you
guys have the rights and they're like
what we have the rights and you know he
was like money how they're like uh I
mean do you think they just like they
know everything are they gonna be
looking they have I think they have a
huge catalog of stuff and all of these
places do and some of it's just complete
garbage that they've collected over the
years they're acquiring Production
Studios and they have the rights and
this and that and it's you know that's
why it's difficult for you know
independent filmmakers be like hey I
want to do this thing but I can't
because you own the IP to it so I need
to make an agreement either you sell it
to me or uh you help put the backing to
actually fund the next production of it
and so
in that story he talks about Universal
realizing they had the rights to it and
he kind of goes over the plan and I'll
try to find the video but he kind of he
goes over the plan to say like this is
what it would take and so he owns a
movie theater and I think it might be
this one yeah it is yeah or he also pull
it up here's it's at this because he
lives yeah so I think he lives above
yeah so he so Kevin Smith lives above
the theater if I remember correctly what
he was saying and so he's got another
another movie idea
uh that's already written from what he
was saying and it all takes place at a
movie theater so he was like one movie
is that would take place at the at the
theater that I own which is a bunch of
these like people that work in a theater
and kind of the lives that are
surrounded and so he's trying to think
like how can I make these other movies
with also a low barrier of entry and
costs and he's like well one of them
actually takes place at the theater that
I own so that's like already taken care
of then he talked about you know he's
like everything has to do well about
clerks three for the next thing to do
well and Mall Rats 2 is another one
he was talking about
um you know because it's 28 years now
but by the time it's probably made would
be like 30 years so I think one of the
plot
um ideas that Kevin Smith was talking
about was the was the concept of them
having their kids or like kids in the
movie uh that they would be like the
next generation
and then he also talked about I think
two other
films that he was like these are the
other ones like if this doesn't get
greenlit then this one would get moved
up in the bucket and if this one is next
then this one would get moved up in the
bucket so he has at least four or five
films one of them being Mallrats two
another one at the theater that he owns
and I think two more and I can't
remember the names but he went over like
the plot near like the the premise of
these movies he was like here are the
next four to five movies that I have
ready to go whenever uh we can get the
backing right and the other reason too
is there's like two tiers
um of like what types of movies get made
at um at Warner Brothers right and
Warner Brothers says like all right well
if you want to make this movie
big budget movies are in this department
but we don't see you here we see you in
this other department and those movies
are made under I don't know three
million or 4 million or 5 million or
something like that and he needs I think
7 million for Mall Rats too I think is
what I remember him saying and so he was
like oh well it takes a little bit like
just a little bit more but I'm not in
I'm not a big budget movie I'm an
independent you know Department moving I
just need a little bit more funding and
they're like oh we don't do that so I
think there's some back and forth in
negotiating they still have to do but he
talked about the next four to five
movies that he has planned over the next
like five or so years
um to get him to I forget what number in
total okay I think maybe he said 15
movies is what he's directed or created
so far which is amazing and and there's
a there's a whole great list of these
movies and people are putting them in
the chat here uh one of my favorite and
I man now thinking about it like Kevin
Smith sequels I would love to see a
sequel to Dogma
um oh yeah and that's another one
fantastic right fantastic movie that I'd
love to see a um a sequel to I don't
know because they
they kill the Archangel at the end I'm
not gonna destroy it and I I so I saw
someone that says that Kevin Smith
movies don't make money I don't I don't
know the financial side of it but I can
tell you this
when he was giving this talk and
explaining kind of what the plan was he
said that the reason one of the main
reasons that Clark clerks three and the
reason that there's interest from them
be like hey what other projects do you
have right and he's like oh well he's
making money yeah well I think that but
all also the idea that
um when they were talking about it they
figured out that Mall Rats too actually
did much better or sorry uh Clerks 2
actually did much better uh in DVD sales
in Post Theater launch and it was like
they had this crazy UPS upswing of like
people watching after the fact well yeah
now with but with streaming platforms
now and the way that they could sell the
rights to the streaming platforms they
could probably make uh an ass load of
money right on just selling the
licensing and that's why the streaming
platforms and not even releasing it in
theaters releasing an on-streaming point
exactly and that's that and that's
that's how the whole Mall Rats 2 thing
came out because they were like oh well
if you have more of movies like this
then we'll make them and he's like great
I've got them all you know I've got uh
clerks three and they're like okay what
else you got he's like well I got Mall
Rats too and then then that's where the
whole like who owns the property right
or the right because then they gotta
figure out who bought it and when they
bought it exactly and here's the thing
even though we had internet connection
uh problems with Jeremy London that's
why it is so important for for folks to
have access is because of all these new
innovative ways for Creative people to
deliver content to folks where they want
their content and how they want their
content I I think I think it brings in
the new age that's why our show exists I
mean and all reality without the
internet and without the power of you
guys coming here every day to this to
this little Channel
um listening to me yell and scream and
Gabe do as what was that you're you're
not you're not you wouldn't have the
delivery of these types of media with
the resources that we don't have because
we are not funded by George Source we
just are not getting the Sorrows despite
what Republicans may think it's not I
wish I was actually afraid it's you it's
you that supports us it is you the
listener who supports us
um so and we appreciate all your support
rather it's financial support or it's
coming here and chatting every day what
whatever you can manage to do to support
the show because you like the content
that is the support you should show
um for Independent Media same way same
way as like uh Kevin Smith movies if you
like Kevin Smith movies when he releases
it you should find a way to support her
whether it's just to watch it or or
whatever it may be share share a tweet
about it or whatever maybe we should get
Kevin on to talk about um his movies
that might be fun that might be fun you
know it's away from politics but I think
the audience would joy enjoy us talking
to Kevin Smith about his movie so I
appreciate Jeremy coming on even though
he had a few technical difficulties no
problem and oh by the way while we're at
it did you did you get your your no I
don't have my shot I've got a glass of
water here there you go let's cheers
happy birthday Galen
um
oh there we go what do you take a shot
of vodka no Jim Jagermeister man oh God
damn yeah
yeah most people couldn't even talk
after that but I got her down to a
science
I got her down to a science speaking of
science or lack thereof we're gonna go
to bonehead of the week as soon as we
come off the break here so everyone hang
on tight don't go anywhere you know in
the second hour on Friday we got
bonehead of the week and boy it's it's
just always the same oh yeah it's
always the same bonus what
are we gonna do what am I gonna do I
don't get to decide what these boneheads
do and when they do it yeah so everyone
stick around right after this break
bonehead of the week
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Mega
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign podcast
jobs jobs jobs Biden
oh
[Music]
my president has bigger jobs than your
president I don't know you could go on
and on
happened and I'd love to keep going on
and on and on about it but you know what
Friday it's the second hour here Tony
Michael's podcast and it's bonehead of
the week it's time for bone end of the
week
uh also it is somebody said happy
birthday Gabe uh no it's not my birthday
it is Kaylin's birthday oh okay happy
birthday Caitlyn yeah so uh everyone get
in the chat show some support uh uh you
know we we've come a long way with this
show a long way with this show and we
have I don't know right now we got
almost 1200 listeners across sometimes
we get 1200 1400 up to eighteen hundred
uh and you guys are the best audience in
the entire world but MJ Margie Caitlyn
um Robin several of the others they have
been here when we had like a dozen yeah
two dozen people listening live so they
are the OG em van
um and I want to give another shout out
to again all the the the people who are
supporters for the shout out VIPs on my
patreon uh Brandon Brit Brook and janzy
Chris e Margie Robin and MJ and I
couldn't do we couldn't do it without
our great moderators either here Margie
Robin MJ Amanda Cynthia we we appreciate
um having the best audience in the world
the best moderators here on on YouTube
um it is a pleasure it is a pleasure and
really I'm just kind of stalling here
because I'm trying to
I'm trying to load the uh the bonehead
acids oh man we were having such um
trouble with Jeremy's audio and stuff
today
she's with you you ever forget you ever
forgot
sometimes I wake up out of bed and I say
I don't know who I am and I don't know
what I have to do today but that's okay
we have we have some good boneheads of
course always yeah yeah but but and
again people
that comment on the post and they're
like all three you should do all three
or somebody yesterday was like um
I can't I mean look there's a there's a
allotted amount of time right from
Monday to about Thursday afternoon
evening usually it's like Wednesday at
midnight till Thursday at whenever we
put the pool yeah unless somebody did
something that was really trending all
week they get on it but most of the time
there's something that happens on
Wednesday slash Thursday where we go oh
yeah you know what actually
well and sometimes sometimes like one of
the the candidates on there today it was
on there and you could pick out 15
different things this week that that
person was on the bonehead of the week
like and you'd be like oh yeah that and
oh yeah there's oh okay there's that too
so I mean this is this is we don't I
mean yeah we're choosing them on the
pole but we're not really choosing who
is the biggest bonehead that
week they are doing that yeah it's them
who are being the boneheads if they
don't want to be on it then don't do the
bone-headed thing right
so maybe they should pay attention to
the show speaking of that let's go to
you bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week like I said we get um you know
a cast of characters that are
reoccurring and it looks like
representative Marjorie foot green made
it on there Matt venmo gatz and the
Cheeto dust q and honor Donald Trump
um I I you know it's kind of a coin toss
of who would win I actually this is one
I was like I'm not really sure who's
gonna win this one I was actually
surprised by the outcome were you I
wasn't I wasn't too surprised because of
the one clip that happened well actually
there's a did you know I didn't see this
the the first day but there's a second
clip
of yeah well there's an extended clip
where she says something else yeah yeah
it's just as bone-headed oh Dumber but
yeah but it it just the whole five
billion thing it really yeah like what
an idiot it's so I mean last week she
got owned on the gas prices Ted lewd
took her to school and was like look
this is exactly why Republicans are mad
this is why Marjorie Taylor green is
pissed off about gas prices because Joe
Biden did a good job and he lowered the
gas prices that you guys kept
bitching about
so yeah if you can lower the gas prices
why not do it for the people why not
help out the American people just like I
mean today we just got the job numbers
back and Joe Biden killing it
right well you know what actually and I
know this probably doesn't have anything
to do with bonehead our boneheads
specifically
um but I do want to point out a bunch of
boneheads on Fox news and it is
hilarious because they have to report
this thing right right and it's very
difficult for them to ignore it
um as they really would want to ignore
it but it's hard for them to but it's
hilarious when they have to play these
clips and let me see if I can
find it where in the hell
oh here it is nope that's a different
thing good Lord now that's not it I I
tweeted a lot of oh here it is
okay okay there it is
hurt they even got the alert outfit
you would think that they wouldn't do
this but this is hilarious and when
Brian kill me uh has to say this out
loud I don't I don't know if he was
expecting this or not watch this
Fox News Alert the January jobs report
just released the U.S adding 517
000 jobs last month it was hilarious is
I can't even believe I cannot believe
that Fox News made this graphic yeah
like they made it I'm surprised because
here's the thing you've got a green
upward little Chevrolet triangle and
it's a big mother half a million jobs
right that's a big that's a big graphic
for anyone to take a screenshot of right
to be like Fox News reported that Joe
Biden is in his administration of all
time well you know because the
expectation was like I think their
expectations like 133 000 right right
517 well exceeds that which will also
it's pretty good too right and we'll get
our amendments uh an addendum to this
jobs report where they'll comb through
the numbers a bit more to get it more
refined we always get you always get an
an amendment to the jobs report after
they've done a little more figuring and
I'm sure it'll go up or down but it's
within a margin between 133
000 and 517. this isn't like they were
expecting 600 thousand it was only 5 17.
they were expecting uh 133 and it ended
up being 517
000 jobs now in perspective
um you know you really would have to
dive into the data which we don't do
here
um to know what types I'm sure someone
else is already diving into that oh yeah
they're going to limit all kinds of
negative about it well here's
here's the thing that I want I want
everyone and I and I said this in the
first 30 minutes in the a block in my
rant is that what you have to understand
is that in government in general
especially in a democracy like ours you
you have to put serious people in charge
and you have to rely on them to do the
right things to put the country in a
situation where this can happen now it
may not be under the best circumstance
it may not be the absolute best quality
outcome that you possibly could milk out
of our country but to get this Arrow
going in the right direction and get
what is crazy is the employment rate I I
hate when they call it the unemployment
rate yeah it's so that's so
negative I hate that that's why
I call I I name the show today 50-year
record employment under Biden because
our employment is almost 97 which is
which is is close to Full Employment
that you can get yeah like there there
is no more full employment
um almost in this country besides 97 98
and it's a 50-year record I think 1969
is the last time we saw some
unemployment right all right love that's
right 69 but but it's it's the first
time we've seen it fall to 3.4 since
right 1969. and again I don't like that
it's the unemployment rate so if the
employment rate is damn near 97 in our
economy that's pretty I mean if I were
to give that a grade
I would say yeah that's a A plus
territory right there right it's pretty
good that's pretty cool that's the jobs
report right what let's see how Brian
Kilmeade thinks how good a job this is
I'm sure he'll go on and on and on for
minutes and minutes and minutes okay
hours let's let's listen it's much
stronger than economists expected they
thought 185 000 unemployment drops to
3.4 that's the lowest since 1969. wow uh
meanwhile this story
that that that debt there you go
many ways wow okay let's not whoa easy
on the 1969 thing what easy on
record-breaking numbers can you play it
back to how like when he comes back from
the graphic yeah just look at his face
no smile no smile in Deliverance
eat there yeah he yeah yeah and then
play it through it's almost like he's
trying to hold in a fart
unemployment drops to 3.4 that's the
lowest since 1969. wow uh meanwhile
it is hilarious
it's so fun to watch them eat their own
sandwich and again man everyone
knows if you listen to this show on a
daily basis which you should if
you're not but if you if you watch this
show on a daily basis or listen to the
show on a daily basis you know that I
don't go on and on endlessly about how
great Joe Biden in is and what a
great president he is and I don't own a
flag or a hat or I don't have
bumper stickers and I don't sick
a fan for that son of a I don't do
it now I mean I call spade a spade right
Jesus Christ there's no reason to sit
around bragging but when you have Fox
News that can't spend more than four
seconds I mean four he's
like whoa no no he's breaking numbers
wow anyway so about this story
right let's let's go on do more let's go
on to actual propaganda yeah um as wow
hilarious anyway let's talk about Hunter
Biden's dick right I have no idea if
there was a follow-up to that that clip
on in terms of what was shown after
that's the first time I'm seeing that
clip but watching Brian kill Mead I mean
we've seen Brian Kilmeade make a fool of
himself you know when he was
interviewing uh Herschel Walker during
the campaign asking him questions if he
knew the women or not when in fact
reports came out and testimony or like
you know interviews of the actual uh
mothers of the children that were that
were had that he did not you know even
though he tried to have abortions that
idea that
Brian Kilmeade is a idiot that
that talks about you know uh nonsense
like the rest of the Republican party on
Fox news but Brian Kilmeade is another
person who pushes his propaganda and
they unfortunately have to report on
good news for Biden but they try to do
it in the quickest way fashion
wow anyway so you know it right it will
never get that will never get old now
but they always have to eat the
sandwich because they just they can't
even couple themselves to a decent
reality which allows them a little
leeway when he's doing that like because
he he if he had commentary every day on
Fox news that allowed him a little
leeway even if he leaned right and
believed a certain way and wanted to
have a certain slant on his commentary
I'm a commentator you're a commentator
we know we have to be careful I have to
be careful exactly what I say and for a
lot of different reasons but for the one
reason is I want my commentary for you
the audience to be very consistent and
if and if the commentary is not
consistent you may not take me seriously
now it's easy when you're coupled to
reality in the truth we have a much
easier time with our commentary here
than what some others do like tyt and
Pac-Man in the right wing right people
on the extremes whether it's whether
it's defeatist on the left or it's the
the alt-right on on the right wing they
they because they're not coupled to an
actual reality that the American people
all kind of agree on in a set of facts
that the American people all agree on
you get in this situation where your
commentary just absolutely slaps you in
the face for example this in the kill me
case with the jobs numbers because they
go on and on about how our countries are
shambles and the economy is
horrible and it's all crumbling down
around you which is all all of
it the entirety of their commentary
about the economy is complete utter
because they're just trying to
scare people the same way that David
Pacman he was like oh there's going to
be a red wave and the red waves come and
there's nothing Democrats can do and
they're so useless and oh we're defeated
already which but bit him in the ass it
totally bit him and again there are
there are you know and I said it before
on the show which is like
sometimes you gotta act like a parent
and parents you know they don't lie
necessarily I mean they do but they in
in the sense of like why would you ever
walk in to the midterm elections
assuming you've already lost right by
assuming and taking that mentality then
people come what's the point right why
am I going to go vote murder suppression
that is true motorcycle and then we
learn that night and follow-up how many
races were literally down to hundreds of
votes so when somebody says what's the
point why should I vote my voice doesn't
matter no it absolutely does matter
whether you're on the right or the left
right it doesn't matter well you know it
matters good example a good example
which she's not on the bonehead this
week which I'm surprised Lauren bobert
won by very a very very slim margin and
it's possible it's possible that if
enough people in that District would
have heard commentary that would have
gave them more confidence in going and
voting against your opponent maybe she
would have lost I don't know but let's
talk about a scumbag who did win but
also get bent over a Democrats
knee and spank this week let's start
with uh Matt venmo Getz I'd like to
start there
do you know this we all watch this story
yeah it's flip here's the thing he
decided to
um have an amendment in the Judiciary
Committee where a member of the
Judiciary Committee leads the Pledge of
Allegiance now Democrats don't have a
problem with saying the Pledge of
Allegiance they do have a problem though
with insurrectionist who trying to
overthrow our government which the
symbol
um the Pledge of Allegiance you
know what you mean you mean Hypocrites
too yeah well I mean they are
Republicans they are they are the party
of Santos
um so watch this clip here uh in the
Committee hearing where there is an
amendment to filed on the amendment to
make sure dirty seditious
insurrectionist can't lead the pledge
because they don't believe in it if they
wanted to overthrow I don't know the
constitution in which the pledge is
designed to have Allegiance too
thank you Mr chairman I um you know Mr
Isa just made a reference to how
important it is for us to display our
commitment to the Constitution and to
commit to defend it aggressively
so I'd like to offer an amendment to the
amendment uh adding in the second
paragraph where the chair May designate
an individual to lead the pledge of
allegiance to add the following language
provided however the pledge shall not be
led by an individual who supported an
Insurrection against the government of
the United States in any way
because I think if we adopt this
amendment then we will be truthful in in
representing that stating this pledge is
an affirmation of your defense of
democracy and the Constitution it's hard
to take that claim seriously if in fact
an individual who in any way supported
an Insurrection against the government
United States is allowed to lead the
pledge now this is not at a bad
Amendment on the amendment I actually
don't have a problem with the amendment
I don't have a problem with them leading
the pledge it's the Pledge of Allegiance
Allegiance
um it's in our government it's in a
government building it's in a government
hearing I actually believe that
regardless if you believe someone should
say the Pledge of Allegiance or not I
actually don't believe it's a bad thing
for our elected officials to pledge
allegiance
um to the flag which represents our
Constitution which they have a note to I
know I have a problem with that now I
believe it's everyone's freedom to not
say the Pledge and I think members of
Congress should be able to not say the
Pledge but I don't think it's a bad
thing that they would say to Pledge of
Allegiance much better than actually
standing there and praying in
our in our in our government buildings
when we clearly there's a reason why we
have a separation between church and
state The Pledge completely different
thing I also think that this is a great
Amendment on the amendment where they're
saying hey no no insurrectionist can
lead the pledge because you don't
actually believe in the pledge why would
you lead it I mean it seems it seems
pretty non-controversial if I had to say
so myself right now I will I will say
that I don't think it goes quite far he
goes quite far enough uh David
um Sicilian in his and the
representative from Rhode Island's first
I don't think he goes quite far enough
he should say people not just
insurrections but who who who committed
sedition
by um trying to have fake electors
um submitted fraudulently to the uh the
confirmation of the Electoral College so
that I believe is a little more language
that he could have added but the point
where Matt gets uh becomes the bonehead
here is this moment after that because
it gave at the first part of this clip
he thinks he's got him oh man he thinks
oh yeah baby I got you now about the
Insurrection yeah and he totally gets
just bent over and spanked on the ass
again because he's Matt dancing these
people don't think Pastor nose
right the the other thing too is that uh
Matt Gates he did it while he was on the
beat with Ari melber and he did it I
think a couple other times but you'll
notice in this clip you'll hear Matt
Gates say George
Herbert Walker Bush right right he says
it he says the fullness the full
government name right hHw yeah yeah
which is not confused with W bush right
now instead of just saying George H.W
bush right he goes full name right as if
as if he's proving a point in saying oh
well you know who another person that
was attacked like it's like dude you we
we know who you're talking about and you
saying the full name doesn't make you
any more intelligent and doesn't make
you sound any more coherent to the dumb
point that you want to make
well let's listen to Matt Getz try to
make this point and then get absolutely
Smackdown like a tennis ball at
a at a US Open match so I would ask Mr
gates to accept this friendly Amendment
and I look forward to supporting with
the gentleman yield I first asking about
the amendment
to make sure that someone who led an
Insurrection against United States
doesn't make a mockery of the Pledge of
Allegiance and stand before this
committee with their hand over their
heart claiming to support the
Constitution Mr Cellini my concern would
be if your definition of an Insurrection
is objecting to electors then there
would be many Democrats on the committee
that wouldn't be eligible to lead the
pledge since so many that's not my
definition there's the eating grin
yeah here here here here's what he
believes right is the spike right he's
like oh this is it this is it and he
doesn't know he's running straight into
the wall like he's running straight into
the point launch the last Republican
president gets sworn in abs
I will allow the chairman to determine
whether or not someone has participated
in instruction United States I think
this language is important would the
gentleman further yield I'm asking Mr
Gates will you now accept the amendment
well I'm I'm concerned that that you may
be disqualifying too many of your own
members Mr sister I'm not concerned
about that at all
he's like okay
if they if they are to overthrow the
government
they can't do it it's the same thing
it's like when you hear Republicans try
to argue like oh Hunter Biden did this
okay fine if he did then investigate him
right do it do it there there should not
be this double standard for oh well he's
a Democrat he shouldn't be look if he
did something wrong regardless of what
party affiliation he has or they have or
whatever
do it investigate them don't allow them
to say the Pledge of Allegiance I don't
care make it Level
Playing Field right but the idea that
they want to say oh well this what about
ISM if they can't say the Pledge of
Allegiance then neither can Democrats
all right bet dude let's sure let's
follow it play that game well you know
this this is the same thing because it's
it's projection because this idea that
oh everyone's so unfair to Republicans
because they're Republicans and they
want to call Republicans insurrections
just because they're Republicans and on
and on and on and on and on and they
want to put they want to put political
prisoners in in federal prison because
they have a certain opinion and blah
blah blah listen these
planned organized to have a violent
Insurrection with the proud boys and The
Oath Keepers Rudy Giuliani calling
members of the Senate and the house to
stall to make sure that fake electors
could be delivered to Mike Pence
that and that was the whole key the
whole plan the entire time we're talking
about sedition we're not talking about a
member of Congress of the house or the
Senate having the right to vote to not
certify results that is not what we're
talking about here that's not at all
what we're talking about we're talking
about the act of sedition which I will
say in fact the oath keeper speaking of
The Oath Keepers in their scheme to
stall to have those State electors
delivered to Mike Pence are now
successfully convicted of seditious
conspiracy it is sedition and anyone who
acted in a way to Aid in a bed Trump his
allies The Oath Keepers or anyone else
that was involved in the planning of the
January 6 violent Insurrection you are
seditionist you are insurrectionist and
you were part of the plot to overthrow
our government rather you know it or
realize it or want it to be that or not
so that gets that bonehead I
mean sorry facts don't care about your
feelings you know just a quota just to
quote the uh pseudo fake intellect known
as Ben Shapiro right your feelings
facts don't care about your
feelings you goddamn snowflake speaking
of snowflakes
um Donald Trump
ended up now we did a video on his
little uh Hitler Youth announcement that
he did which I mean that in and of
itself could be uh the bone-headed
moment but the bone-headed moment that I
thought was this week is when he bled
the fifth five million times or some
stupid I don't know yeah I think
it's pretty close out there but this is
this is almost 500 it was almost 500
yeah it was it was nearly 500 because he
almost almost I believe I think it was
like 400 plus but I know that Eric Trump
did 500 Plus or close to 500. so Eric
Trump beat uh his son or his dad rather
uh by by pleading the fifth right and
you know again you've got Donald Trump
who says only Mobsters only the mob
takes the fifth why would you take the
fifth if you're innocent this and this
and that but some of your questions
yeah well here's the clip let's play the
clip the difference in what he said in
the deposition
and the testimony versus what he says to
his supporters because I believe that's
the key here let's listen anyone in my
position not taking the Fifth Amendment
would be a fool an absolute fool if
you're innocent why are you taking the
Fifth Amendment
I know I don't know it would it would
make me seem like you have something to
hide which probably means that you're
not innocent I mean just base just based
on that logic which again is Trump
showboating in public trying to seem
like this Alpha Mega Man like I'm a
patriot I won't cuck to anyone
he is and then when he's in a deposition
he's like uh for the sake of um not um
uh you know making myself uh in trouble
I plead the fifth like that's exactly
what happens and then he did that he's
like same answer same answer same answer
right 500 times well you know the the
best part about this is when he's giving
some of this deposition and he's saying
oh it's so unfair to me I'm said it's so
unfair we're so mistreated I'm such a
I'm such a little I'm such a whiny
little and kiss James is so mean
to me oh she's so mean she even
campaigned that she would get me if I
did crimes she achievement campaigned
and promised that if I did crimes and
she found tax fraud that she would that
she would bring me to Justice in any way
shape if they found tax fraud yeah I
would hope that you would go to I mean
Law and Order just comply just
compliance right exactly just like
you've got nothing to hide just because
why but but the fact that tis James is
sitting across the table from him and he
has his head down the whole time and he
barely will look up at her barely will
look look up at her because he's so
terrified of her because you
know she's sitting there oh yeah and
she's laser eye she's just
hanging you know I look you know the
off camera she's like you know
having a drink eating some chips she's
like this is even more delicious now oh
but you know that she's she's in the
back you know she's behind obviously and
she's just watching She's she is living
in oh you know it because he looks up he
looks up when job I think this is a clip
of that let's watch this
one in my position
I take in the Fifth Amendment would be a
fool there he looks absolute fool
one statement or answer that is
ever so slightly off just ever so
slightly by accident by mistake
such as it was a sunny
a beautiful day when actually it was
slightly overcast
would be met by law enforcement under
the advice of my Council and for all of
the above reasons I respectfully
declined to answer the questions under
the rights and privileges afforded to
every citizen under the United States
Constitution
okay so there there's a little clip of
him getting cut yeah and not only and
not only did he plead the fifth right
and have to have to look down as he said
it right but he came prepared with a
written statement in case you know
because I'm sure his lawyers were like
Hey listen Donnie uh baby uh we need you
to plead the fifth or else you're going
to incriminate yourself for some other
crime that they're gonna ask you about
and just to make sure that you say
exactly what you need to say because we
know that you like to rant we've seen
your videos we need you to stick to the
script we're gonna write this
pre-written statement on this piece of
paper for you all you got to do is read
it make your statement if you forget
they have to say same answer it's
written on the piece of paper for you
same answer same answer I plead the
fifth I don't want to you know criminal
myself under advice of counsel I plead
the fifth
we're going to have these answers ready
to go for you and you can read them just
in case but we know you will forget what
to say so for your own good
take this piece of paper and just put it
in front of you and whenever you feel
nervous and whenever you feel uncertain
just look down and follow the steps well
you know he kind of goes off script and
here's part of that where he's going off
script
she promised to quote shine a bright
light into every dark corner of Trump's
real estate holdings
shortly thereafter she vowed to quote
use every area of the law to investigate
president Trump and his business
transactions and that his
that of his family as well
she knows nothing about us this is when
she knew absolutely nothing about us it
was very unfair
this whole thing is very unfair there he
is Off Script
I'm the victim I committed these crimes
at my company and I said I didn't know
but I really did know and that I had
weiselberg take the fall who's now I
don't know if you saw this weisselberg
is now being potentially going to be
charged with another crime oh no
well you know I actually surmised the
morning that this deposition tape
dropped and that there was the the
um news that the Manhattan D.A had
opened up another grand jury
um into Donald Trump personally possibly
for the crimes of of the actual Stormy
Daniels case my question was is Alan
weiselberg being squeezed because Rikers
is a listen being locked up
is a I don't know if anybody's
been he only has to be his sense is only
five months yeah but five months in
Rikers oh yeah
what is he 70 he's like 75 or something
like that listen being locked up as a
being being incarcerated is
a trust me but when when you're
talking about Rikers holy
you're talking about a whole nother
ball game you're talking about a
whole nother type of sentencing and
incarceration at Rikers the situation
there is not good like it is so horrible
that they should actually probably shut
that facility down if it's not totally
reformed from top to bottom but that
that is for another time in another
debate but my guess is When Alan
weisselberg actually got there to do his
five months he soon realized holy
yeah I really stepped in a big pile
right on that one right maybe maybe I
should do something to get my uh get my
five months reduced here or something
right or try at least to reconcile this
situation especially if they were going
to bring other charges against him so
what are these other charges real quick
before we move on so I mean just to keep
it simple basically they're looking at
additional fraud charges against him uh
that you know insurance fraud to
pressure him to cooperate with their
investigation against Trump so who knows
maybe he cooperates and he gets less of
a letter you know a lesson sentence from
the five months down to something less
or maybe they say you know what we'll
just wipe the whole thing and you can do
uh kind of house arrest but again it all
depends on how much or what information
weisselberg is willing to give and
cooperate with because yeah you know
being in Rikers for five months at the
age of the the age of 75 is not easy on
anyone especially if there's someone in
there who I don't know wants to
settle a score let's say right
um and you want to live out or make a
name for themselves exactly right you
know and if you're in that position then
you might want to negotiate to say hey
guys look I know I know I said I didn't
know anything before but I do have some
information now you know
um and it's it is it is
with time especially at Rikers you'd be
surprised how much time like okay okay
yeah I'm I'm I'm good to talk to you you
change your mind about a lot of things
when you're incarcerated and I'm sure
the Mind changing that happens when
you're incarcerated at Rikers is
overwhelming speaking of frauds speaking
of frauds again another big huge fraud
but he's just he's just a republican
really he's just a republican but he
ended up being our dishonorable mention
this week of course it's George Santos
the reason why we didn't put George
Santos on because George is dishonorable
mention oh yeah that sorry
the Santos honorable man the same
terrible mention yeah which um we've
come to we're not sure if George Santos
is Ron desantos or if Ron desantos is
George Santos we're not really sure yet
we're still working on that nailing that
one down but uh George George Santos
here he I think he's four out of five
the last time he he's been on the pole
so I thought he would win if we put him
on so we squeezed in the other three but
I do want to play a clip here that you
posted um from your what was that
account on on Twitter
um and I I don't know exactly why there
could be a million reasons why and
that's not and that was the because I I
think I know what you're gonna play but
it was all because of uh
I was like I was I've been watching as
we all have I've been watching this uh
this George Santos uh
situation play out and you're like man
who is the situation situation play out
and you're like who is this guy where is
he from every every single day or every
other day there's some new little bit of
news that somebody uncovers right and uh
it's either he is formerly a drag queen
in Brazil which again nothing wrong with
that but when you back a party and
you're part of a party that is
anti-trans anti-drag anti-lgbtq you know
you you back people that that have
secret money operations against the
equality act when you yourself are
supposedly married to your husband you
know you're gonna get called out for
those things and I think you're gonna
are you playing the the well I'm trying
to I'm trying to find the one clip where
he says um he basically says I'm not
which one is it where he's not he's not
he's not he didn't lie he didn't
misrepresent anything but it's the
interview on oan it's that clear yeah
yeah let me tell him
um I got there's three of them here but
I don't see the one oh I think it's the
first one where he's talking about it's
uh
not a lie okay like categorically right
is this it is this the uh let's let's
play this one um you were actually the
first one to post this
um and then a few days later other
people jumped onto this but uh here's
here's an interview with
um the scam-charian candidate George
Santos himself on oan you know a real
news
network and I know that a lot of people
want to create this narrative that I I
faked my way to Congress which is
absolutely categorically false
okay yeah do I need to play any more
than that I mean this is hilarious you
should you should okay let's keep going
um I've worked hard I've built ground up
a career
um through experience and through
knowledge and through self uh education
and you know I think it's amazing that I
he forgot fraud he forgot fraud in there
he built a he built himself up with with
fraud money and you know who's counting
it's on our way in what are you gonna do
I have to sit here and be spoken down to
on a regular basis yet again by the
media
he lied to people he defrauded
his constituents and he is on you to
point it out is just egregious oh my God
he is on oan okay of all places right
oan
the worst of the worst the worst the the
what he's on oan and
I'll give I'll give I'll give uh Caitlyn
Sinclair I think is her name credit like
she asked him some questions right and
she did her research on some of the
stuff especially when it comes to like
how how his constituents feel about
George Santos and the lies that he's
told and whether or not he's given them
an apology and even so he was like oh
yeah I gave them an apology and she's
like well not according to the
constituents he goes well I don't know
what more you want me to do I I don't
know here actually play that clip
um the the second one
are the third one I've learned my lesson
is it the no it's
here we'll play we'll play uh this one
here
and I've learned my lesson and you can
guarantee I can guarantee you that from
now on anything and everything is always
going to be above board I mean it wasn't
before yeah because it wasn't really
saying which which he then says he goes
oh wait Elizabeth let's largely always
been above board I'm just gonna largely
largely largely I would love to know his
definition of largely it was largely
above board people huge it was huge
largely I mean Trump has largely hands
right yes
so that's probably exactly what George
Santos is talking about but yeah is it
the other clip that you were I think
there's enough there's it's a different
clip in there uh maybe the 30th yeah oh
yeah here it is here it is here's the
one that you're referring to yeah
I'm sad that the media has decided now
to Target oh my God family
the media has decided to Target and
harass my friends
anybody around me they're not your
friends I signed up for this job Caitlyn
oh no I signed up for this so why are
you bitching if you signed up for this
why the are you bitching the idea
that he's like this is about me this is
my campaign no actually it wasn't just
about you it's about the district that
you represent but also when you entered
yeah and when you enter the spotlight of
an of a campaign and say I am gonna run
for office then people are gonna look
into your life and that includes
everyone that you've ever dealt with
when you where you've gone to school
what sports you might have played or not
played and and your family because they
want to know is there a reason that we
shouldn't be your mom died once twice
three times who knows right right and
yeah I mean I mean the fact that he's
saying everyone's bringing his family
into it the only reason why anyone talks
about his family at all in this story is
because he died yeah about not only not
only his mother and her death and and
the possibility that she died during 9
11. but he's talked about how he's
Jewish because he has lineage back to
the Holocaust which we don't know if
that's true or not oh it's not because
his grandparents were catholic and they
were from Brazil right so and he he goes
on and on and on about these lies about
his family that he's told out in
the open it ain't like it ain't like he
told these lies 20 years ago to a friend
and the friends coming up like well he
lied to me about right no you said this
in front of cameras and microphones
you stole a scarf when you went
to the January 6th celebration where you
wanted to overthrow the Constitution to
install Donald Trump as dictator and
King even even when you went to
perpetuate that why you stole a
scarf from your friend that you call it
your roommate get the out of here
with this medius dragging your friends
because
because at the end of the day if he did
actually come forward in the sense of
like oh I made mistakes fine whatever
but even if before that you know he
actually told the truth none of this
would have been about him or his family
and if anything it was about his family
it would be like oh George Santos a gay
Republican non-white person
representative or representing the blue
state of New York right which we don't
even really know of any of that is
hardly right exactly like you know
they're like oh well is he married he
says he's got a husband but when you
look back through the timeline it
doesn't really add up he references this
guy but we don't actually know if that's
him we know that he was married to a
woman from uh uh
I don't give a I don't give a
if you if if what your sexual preference
is who you're married to I don't give a
but when you are when you are
entering public life especially when
you're asking voters to give you their
ballot to you so you can go represent
them in the United States House of
Representatives and you're lying to them
and really the lie that I think really
has pissed these constituents off more
than anything else like there they would
get over anything because he is a
republican he's a republican they are
used to being lied to by these
scumbags the one thing that I think the
reason why New York's third will never
ever consider George Santos as a viable
candidate of any political party in New
York's third ever again and they're so
pissed off at him and they would recall
him if they could oh yeah is because of
his lie about 9 11. that is the one
thing that put them over the top because
it's so personal it's still wound I
think not only 911 but also that I think
if I remember correctly I mean also New
York but that District specifically I
think has a large population of Jewish
Americans right and the fact that he
said Jewish and then and then the thing
where he had the dog charity and he used
a Jewish name all the things they were
like this is It's a Jews will give me
more money it's basically the sentiment
that he had which is the idea medic
right and the whole yeah the whole idea
that he's like oh Jewish people and
money it's like okay immediately right
there we already have anti-semitism
isn't because you were assuming that
those people have the money and they
control the money and there's right and
they only and they only give it they
only give it to other Jewish people like
it's just ridiculous but he
that's why that's why he's the
dishonorable mention of the week because
he is a bonehead but he's just
an every average day Republican he just
tells a little bit different lies than
what they want to tell they want to lie
to you about Eminem's and gas stoves and
inflation yeah and gas prices he wants
to lie about 9 11 and if he was a drag
queen or not which I don't know why he's
ashamed of that I have no idea but you
know our next person
on bone of the week has a lot to be
ashamed of and he's running away from
that shame I think is the story that
we're gonna get to here I don't know I
haven't done a lot of research on this
story yet I know this guy is a complete
scumbag but he made his way this
morning last minute as Alpha cook on
bonehead of the week it is the murderer
that's right Kyle I called you a
murderer Kyle Rittenhouse
um the white supremacist murderer sue me
is there I feel like
I say I'm saying these things so maybe
he'll try to I think it would be great
to elevate my status that I was sued by
Kyle right now yeah I really do Kyle you
are a white supremacy or white
nationalist you are racist piece of
and you are a murderer come sue
me for it yeah and I'll keep saying it
over and over and over again and you
know what if you if you sue then it
let's bring out the discovery baby
that's right you know what's funny about
that is I think that's why he ended up
on bonehead because he's being sued is
that right that is correct he is being
sued so why is if if he's just being
sued why is he on the bonehead what
happened right so just for the context
of why he's being sued so a federal
judge in Wisconsin ruled on Wednesday
that a wrongful death lawsuit that was
filed by the father of one of the men
who was shot and killed by Kyle written
murdered let's call this murdered by
Kyle Rittenhouse during the 2020 protest
in uh in Wisconsin that again Kyle
Greenhouse never had to be at and not
only that but he never had to be at and
have an AR-15 that he had a friend
purchase because he was not old enough
and he could not actually own a gun but
he stored it in Wisconsin and then his
mother drove him 30 minutes over across
the border into another state to go
attend this riot
with an ulterior motive motive right so
the reason
that he's getting sued is for the death
of Anthony Huber right the murdering of
Anthony Huber which is one of the two
men that that Kyle renounce murder now
this is a little different than his
criminal trial where the judge made it
to where it was very easy for Kyle
Rittenhouse right right to get off on
murder charges this is a civil case this
is a civil case so this is a lawsuit
that was filed in 2021 okay
now what happened was in that time frame
right
attorneys and investigators spent more
than a hundred hours and across seven
different states where they finally
tracked his mother's home or where she
was staying in Florida and they said uh
they said Kyle isn't home right he's not
home you can't give us this right
but turns out that uh they can because
it was clear to the judge
that Kyle Rittenhouse
was cowardly running away from getting
served this lawsuit right getting to
serve the papers by you've been served
right here is this if you think it would
just go away if he wasn't served I think
maybe maybe Kyle Rittenhouse thought ah
you know what if I act like Rudy
Giuliani or Donald Trump or any other
Republican and I run away from the
problem maybe it'll go away but here's
the thing eventually it's gonna catch up
with you right you're gonna get served
and in this way it was by proxy of his
sister at his mother's home or wherever
she was staying in Florida you know what
this is good enough this is close enough
to a person to Kyle writtenhouse because
this guy has been jumping from state to
state to state and they but he did get
officially served for this but he was
officially served and not only but a
federal judge in Wisconsin said yeah we
can proceed with this civil lawsuit
against Kyle Rittenhouse for this
wrongful death so I I look around and
find out is What's Happening Here I
think this is significant and the reason
why is this not just that Kyle
Rittenhouse murdered these people
um because you know he should be serving
uh criminal penalties uh for that I
believe now the way the trial happened
and the judge you know framed up the
trial it didn't happen that way we
didn't receive Justice
um in the Kyle Rittenhouse case I don't
believe but here's the thing
if you'll remember if you rewind all the
way back to where Kyle rittenhouse's
lawyer who got him off on these charges
did an interview and said I have told
Kyle
to go away slink away change
your name duplex whatever you
gotta do to not beat Kyle Rittenhouse go
do that do not participate in a media
campaign do not try to make money off
your name do not try to advance your
your platform because of because
you got off on these murder charges go
away live your life and live it free of
this this criminal charges that attorney
said that out loud in several
interviews that that was his advice to
Kyle Rittenhouse but he also said he
doesn't think Kyle is listening to him
and the reason why this civil case
it makes so much sense to me is because
Kyle Rittenhouse you gotta have money to
be jumping from state state to state to
state to be avoiding I mean a broke
who has to stay in one spot
and eat peanut butter and jelly
sandwiches and ramen noodles
can't skip town right and Skip
being served he's making money he did
the video game uh he's been on several
places uh he's gonna he was a seven
different universities he's been paid to
be a speaker he was on Tucker Carlson
show I mean he on and on and on he was
going to sue the media he was going to
get all this money pursuing Joe Biden
yeah I thought he was supposed to be
holding the media accountable right he
goes it's time to hold the media
accountable but because he played into
that that grift and he's grifting he's
making money somewhere which only he's
got a he's Gotta Give send go that's
going right I don't know if you know
that and he's like please help me I'm
being persecuted
I need legal fees that I'm gonna use for
my living purposes listen folks the
reason why a federal judge is more
likely to let a civil lawsuit go forward
for monetary value is because Kyle
written house is profiting profiting off
the murder just like Alex Jones was
profiting off the lies that he
told about children being slaughtered at
at Newtown look that is why Kyle
writtenhouse is a idiot that
lawyer who got him off on the
criminal murder charges if he would have
just listened to that murder and went
away we wouldn't know who Kyle
Rittenhouse really is where he's at what
he's doing and he probably would not be
be able to be sued because he wouldn't
have anything to get sued for there's
nothing there there's no way there's no
gain that he would make off of a
wrongful death okay that's the same
reason why O.J Simpson has to give all
his money for the book that he
wrote to it the family because
he made profit off that case so
Karen house
um and it's not just you know and just
so people know it's not just Kyle
Rittenhouse that's being sued also
government officials in the state of
Wisconsin uh because of essentially I
think is what they quoted they said by
creating a powder keg of a situation
where this was able to happen so it's
not just the person Kyle Rittenhouse the
murderer but also government officials
in the city being responsible for
allowing that to happen and also just
again creating that but another thing
too is that Kyle Rittenhouse
The Audacity Of Kyle Rittenhouse to say
oh oh oh this whole lawsuit is is
guys this whole case against me
should be dismissed because I wasn't
properly served a lawsuit
but meanwhile they're like yeah it's
because you were it was clearly clearly
you evading getting served right
that is not gonna hold up in court
where the court the court is the one
trying to serve you and you're like oh
well you didn't serve me properly yeah
okay good luck with that defense they're
Kyle yeah good luck
um speaking of non good luck and not
having luck at all
um let's go back to our contestants here
Marjorie Taylor green she doesn't have
luck with numbers it's almost it's
almost like them Banning math and
reading and stuff
um really has effect on their cognitive
you know
um knowledge of like math and numbers
and how works because she ended up
being our bonehead of the week she ended
up being our bone of the week now
there's probably I don't know four or
five different clips that we could play
a Marjory Taylor green uh for the
bonehead there's actually a good
exchange I believe with AOC
um or AOC yesterday and I and I probably
yeah yeah maybe I'll do this too on my
um patreon I'll play that video and
maybe I'll do like a video response on
there because we just we don't have time
to get to every single piece of
content and it's a great piece of
content I mean for the same reason that
we're like oh God you know it's
literally until Thursday that we pick
some of these contestants it's there is
so much going on
at all that is why we need three hours
but we we just we have to have more
monetary support before we could get to
three hours because we probably could
just do eight hours a day if we I mean
yeah if we wanted I mean we've done it
before right just for just uh court
cases right but I'm sure if we really
did want to yeah we could go eight hours
it just becomes uh you know because is a
financial yeah right well you got to eat
you got to pay so you know family
significant others might be like hey you
want to ever spend time with me you know
they might they might get a little
pissed off but here is the um here's the
uh the clip of Marjorie Taylor green now
I'm gonna play the the end of the clip
that we didn't play the other day but
this first part of the clip is really
bone-headed so let me set this
up for you this is a this is a uh
committee meeting where Marjorie Taylor
green is going to be questioning a
government official about education
funding and she she doesn't know the
name of the bill that is the coveted
relief package she calls it covet cash
because she's in her bubble and she
doesn't realize that this person has no
clue what what she's talking
about she brings up CRT he has no
clue what she's talking about
she bring she brings up
um wokism in a way and and yeah and it
it just just watch it's
confusing but this is why she's a
bonehead
can you tell me uh how much how much
coveted cash went to CRT
okay so that's your question right
literally this is like that they
would talk about on Steve Bennett's show
now to be fair we've got our own
language on this show and someone who is
not
um you know
knowledgeable on politics would come
watch our show some of what I say and
what we talk about would seem like
foreign language right it really
would
but we're not in a Committee hearing I'm
not responsible
for representing my constituents and
asking serious questions to a witness in
Congress in a Committee hearing here she
is and her question is hey back covered
cash did you need that Cove Cash go to
CRT and watch
this he's like what the watch this
CRT critical race Theory and education
it's it's a racist uh uh curriculum used
to teach children uh that somehow their
white skin is not equal to black skin
and other things in it okay so she
doesn't know what CRT is nor nor can she
explain her alternative definition to
crit but I think the actual definition
and then she doesn't even know what she
means when she says it yeah and I just
want to I just want to put this out here
if I was ever called before a committee
okay a congressional meeting like this
for something I said or that might not
that might not be a bad idea we should
get you in a uh yeah yeah I don't know
what for could be good but if there is
ever a moment in time in which I am
called in to a congressional meeting
before a committee like this especially
ones with idiots and they ask me
questions right you mean idiots asking
the question yeah yeah yeah idiots
asking the questions if they ever ask me
stuff like you know just an example like
if I was in the situation right now and
they're saying uh
CRT and this covered cash
I would because I don't know if of if
this this comptroller that she's talking
to is doing it intentionally or he
actually was like I couldn't hear what
you said or couldn't understand what you
said well he does that later on but it's
a little different right where he's like
I think you said this
what I would say is I'm sorry I don't I
don't know can you explain that because
what it allows you to do is take control
because what what she's trying to do
right now is saying CRT she's trying for
that fox but she's trying for that Fox
nude moment she really wants that gotcha
moment with those catch phrases right
but catch phrases and like oh that's a
good like that was a good Zinger or
whatever it might be doesn't work when
the person on the other end either
doesn't know what you're talking about
or plays Dumb and says wait what are you
talking about and then you have to
explain it right because the assumption
is when she says oh CRT and covet Cash
She it makes her sound like oh yeah I
know what I'm talking about but when you
question it be like I'm sorry can you
explain that like I didn't hear what you
said or can you talk a little bit more
about that it allows her to reveal that
she actually is this idiot that
doesn't know anything and the only
talking point she has is regurgitating
the phrases
um the the uh the new interpreter that
Tucker Carlson or Steve Bannon or anyone
Newsmax Orient does and then she has to
explain it and she gets she gets caught
in a lie or in a in a little bit of like
uh moment like she was a kid in class
and the teacher says Hey so uh Marge can
you get up and and give us a
presentation on last week's lesson plan
or last night
um uh well the the CRT gazpacho police
came and uh they told uh you know it's
it's just here's the other thing that's
happening here's the other thing that's
happening that you can't see in this
clip
she's been a congressperson for two
years she was re-elected to
Congress because she did such a great
job right the problem is that Marjorie
Taylor green did not have committee
assignments no reason right but the way
we can debate that and that's a whole
nother story she didn't have committee
assignments for a very good reason
here's the thing
because she didn't have any committee
assignments she didn't have any serious
staffers there's no staffers in
Washington DC that want to go work for a
congressperson who have no committee
assignments and the reason why is
because in Washington DC there's career
staffers that's what they do for a
living and when a congressperson like
Madison cawthorne does not get reelected
they go to George soros's office and
they are staffers for them you mean
George Santos
yes Jesus Christ I dude I've made the
same mistake too I was talking to
somebody I was like oh George sorrelson
like what see this is the stupid
language that they do and then it's all
anyway Santos George Soros Rhonda
Santos is yeah these
but listen that there's
career staffers so what's happening
behind the scenes that you do not see is
that staffers when you go and and you
watch C-SPAN every once in a while or
you watch clips of it where someone's
doing questioning like we watched um um
the the representative from Rhode Island
and uh do the amendment to the amendment
right right
he's a professional he understands
what's happening he's an adult right he
has but he has professional staff behind
him right that are also queued in on
this and they know what's happening
because a representative has a lot of
things that they're doing all at once
there's a lot of votes that they're
making but they have staff that keeps
track of everything for them because
there's so much stuff Marjorie Taylor
Green's staff sucks they're
horrible they're not professionals they
don't know what the hell they're doing
they don't know how to form questions
they don't even know how to write
questions on paper she looked at the
paper and literally read why is there
coveted cash being paid for CRT and that
is how they wrote the question
and more than likely she wrote that
question not her staff and she did not
run it by her staff because what a real
professional would have done here if
they wanted to pin this guy down is
explain what covet cash is explain what
CRT is in her little mind and
her delusion and then asked the question
and form the question and ask the
question so he understood what the
he was talking about but he doesn't
because it gets better with the with
where he does have no clue what she's
talking about and of course she up
the whole five-point right and again
this is zillion million dollars this is
her first moment back right with
responsibility being on this committee
to be like okay I'm gonna be able to ask
questions
this is her she's like up to
back first time right she's been injured
she just got off the injured person or
whatever and she's in at the best break
no she's in a fast break man there's no
one in front of her she's at the half
court line she's gonna dunk that
ball man you gotta dunk that and
she goes up the beaut a beautiful
lift off and then bang off the
back of the rim watch this watch this
education yeah uh no I do not know that
but I I do know that there's Provisions
that the uh federal funds generally are
not used they're supposed to be used for
curriculum oh that's a statement oh Mr
datero I have to tell you in Illinois
that they received 5.1 billion
um at an elementary school there that
that used it for equity and diversity
um so it's it's being used for these
things uh
so there she lies can you pull me the uh
the dry cleaning clip I don't have that
one on this one can you find that what
you were talking about I think so yeah
pull me the dry cleaning clip and uh
everyone will know what I'm talking
about when we pull this up because he
gets really confused about dry cleaning
but but she's really confused about a
number because the real story is is that
the entire state of Illinois we did a
whole thing on this you should subscribe
to the YouTube channel to go watch this
but the entire state of Illinois
received
five gazillion billion trillion dollars
not one elementary school and all 50
states not just Illinois received money
yeah for the same relief for eight
education one 81 billion dollars is how
much money was given to all 50 states in
the state of Illinois has 851 school
districts okay that's that's districts
that's not the schools in those
districts now some districts get more
money than other districts because
they're larger they need more resources
you know they they need uh to to help
those teachers by getting additional
staff or or how whatever might or Aid
they got the state of Illinois got five
billion dollars not a single Elementary
School
if that was the case because I said like
five billion dollars for one school is
in an elementary school is crazy
well but this comes down back to her
staff and making sure that on her notes
that they clearly show and form a
sentence and thoughts for her because
she cannot form them on her own that the
facts are laid out in a certain way that
doesn't present her stupidity and her
bone-headedness for everyone to see the
same as this clip this is the follow-up
this is what she says after that which I
don't know which is more boneheaded but
let's watch zero can you tell me how
much money was given to drag queen Story
Hour
that I'm sorry could you repeat that
drag queen Story Time where where men
dress up as women and read confusing
books to children at first I thought you
said Dry Clean
he says she says drag queen story are
okay now
again we we they've gone on and on and
on about this stuff and really
um you know it is funny that this guy
thought she said drag or instead of drag
queen story thought he said she said dry
clean but in all reality like there are
people's lives at risk here people are
getting shot and killed people are being
threatened uh I mean violence they're
threatening to use violence against
people they're calling in and
threatening bomb threats at Children's
Hospitals over all this I mean all this
North Carolina a few uh nonsense that
Matt Walsh and the daily wire and
Marjorie Taylor green and Fox News is
perpetuating by demonizing performers
who dress up and do dances and they want
to promote kids reading
um and and by performing and making
reading interesting and entertaining
they think that someone dressing up in a
certain outfit is is sexual and that is
their problem that is a problem they
have about their sexuality and the thing
things that they are repressing I guess
because nothing about a man dressing uh
as a woman is sexual in any way shape or
form that's not at all and I mean this
is the same group of people who you know
not only try to overthrow the government
but they attack
lgbtq communities and an example I was
mentioning a moment ago was North
Carolina and I don't know if people
remember this but this didn't happen too
long ago this was back in December when
uh North Carolina town was attacked on
their power grid because of a uh a show
that they had it was very strategic they
shot up very several conversations
Moore County uh because you know they
had a local drag show to celebrate the
LGBT community again dude it's a private
venue
that they're doing their own thing
they're not bothering you they're not
touching you they're not trying
to touch your dick or like
Matt schlapp of CPAC none of
that they're not the people no
Republican no Republican would ever
grope or groom or molest or rape or
sexually there's only a whole list
child pornography none of that stuff but
in Moore County in North Carolina Moore
County local drag show Private entity
private thing they're doing their own
thing for the lgbtq community and and
the Republicans these extremists these
violent terrorists because that's what
they are and and they're stoked uh by
by Tucker Carlson and oan and and daily
wire daily wires Matt Walsh and Matt
Walsh
garbage and so when you've got people
like Marjorie Taylor green who again
first opportunity to come back and say
I'm a real person and I actually want to
legislate law she goes in and she talks
about coveted cash and drag show Story
Time like these are the people that we
have to that we unfortunately for the
next two years or however long depending
on when they're elected have to deal
with because they're representing the
American people and their constituents
when that's not actually what they're
there to do they're there to make money
they're there to push propaganda they're
there to indoctrinate you against any
anti-anything
anti-American values they say America
first but they're anti-america first
they don't like equality they don't like
Equity they don't like anyone who isn't
white they don't like the ability for
anyone to have opportunity to make it in
the American dream you know
quote-unquote American Dream
they only like it if they themselves
and people who look like them are able
to prosper enter this under this uh
America first uh Banner right but we
know that's not the case and they will
they will go in and invade your privacy
they will look at under your you know
your skirt and in your pants they will
tell you what bathroom you can go to
they'll try to give physical exams to
children
they go to the links Gabe Sanchez of
banning entire libraries in schools
because they're terrified of one book
they want to ban a movie from the 1990s
Missed Out Fire because Liberals are
like okay so you're against men and drag
but you're gonna like you're gonna be
okay with Mrs that this is not new men
dressing up as women are in women's
clothes is not new it's not new it's not
sexual it's only it's only you who are
making Etc you scumbags but here's
here's the follow-up here
um and what made Marjorie Taylor green
the bonehead of the week watch so I'm
sorry uh no I don't know the answer to
either one of those two oh we need to
look into this and I I urge you to do
that um they uh Bradberry Sullivan LGBT
community center in Pennsylvania
received sixteen thousand dollars uh for
drag queen story time uh from from
coveted cash
um I think this is an issue that needs
to be looked into a lot of this money
went to things that should have never
gone to like your business so much and I
yield back the remainder of my time I
yield back the remainder of my time and
the reason why is because I lost all
thought all direction for my stupid
questioning here because really
in all honesty it has no substance
whatsoever for my constituents or the
American people are really in this
committee that shouldn't exist in the
first place right she's like I totally
lost my train of thought on what
Breitbart and news and War Room uh
segment I was supposed to be
regurgitating from Steve Bannon right
right that is I forgot it I forgot to
write write it down yeah I didn't write
it down and I didn't have the definition
such a bonehead I'm such a
bonehead I can't come up with
the thought that might give me the
reason why I even ran for congress in
the first place Marjorie Taylor green
you have been on bone net of the week
several times it's been a while I'm glad
you're back here on the bonehead of the
week everybody let's give her her do
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
you did it you did it once again
I think she used to be the record holder
for uh the amount he was she she was
undefeated for a while you know anytime
she was in she was like a sure sure in
but uh she kind of lost her footing
we'll see if she comes back especially
hoofing her Roofing she was like nothing
her hoofing she ain't got a footage
we'll see maybe maybe
she comes back she has like a a
Resurgence a Marjorie Taylor green
assons we'll call it more more of these
moments in these committees could
definitely get work her way onto
bonehead of the week everybody you know
bone end of the week is every single
Friday here on the Tony Michaels podcast
in the second hour and a clip on the
Midas touch Network do not forget here's
how you vote Gabe Sanchez you go to our
channel the Tony Michaels podcast go to
YouTube search the Tony Michaels podcast
subscribe you go to the community tab
the poll will be there every Thursday
you can also vote on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pot so follow us on elon's
Twitter at Tony Michael's pod you can
vote there also download every single
episode of our podcast
on Apple's Spotify Google and make sure
to catch it on Fridays in the the full
entirety of the second hour of course we
we've been going long on Fridays because
of bonehead because it's such a great
segment and I'm not gonna not go along
because of Bonin that's for damn sure
but make sure make sure you go down load
every single episode and again get us to
20 000 subscribers Tony Michael's
podcast on YouTube very very super
important super woo that's been your
addition of bone in a week if you're on
our show aren't live we have several
announcements right after this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week
bone-in of the week so we got a couple
announcements to make number one I want
to thank Jeremy London for sticking with
us yeah any other guests and like
this I'm done he was committed and I'm
glad because he had you know he had a
good story a great story I'm glad he
came I'm glad he told the story I'm glad
he told us about Mall Rats too I'm
excited about the possibility of having
more Kevin Smith sequels that's that's
exciting
um so thank you Jeremy again once again
and my friend we'll have you back again
whether your internet's good or not uh
it worked the audience loved it the
audience heard you even though I had the
whole we gotta find a way
to allow to pipe it in to pipe yeah to
call in so that they can hear you know
both of us and right we and as a backup
as well yeah yeah because they couldn't
he couldn't hear Gabe yeah yeah because
I have my headphones on that's why I
think I think I I think I know how okay
well we'll figure that out yeah figure
out a plan B we'll figure out a plan
because we had we had several guests
this week we had a Texas poll we had
Hi-Fi from the radicalized Pod and then
we had Jeremy London yeah and from all
Rants and he told us a great story about
how he he's trying to get his dad back
um from the Trump Abyss right but he's
doing it but he's doing other
announcement I want to make again I want
to give a shout out and thanks to
Brandon Britt Brook James Z Chris E mark
Margie Robin and MJ as the shout outs
for patreon thanks to all your support
over on patreon uh a few people
requesting some different tiers so I'm
working on some different ideas of what
I can do for some different tiers
because people wanted
um some different tiers other than 5 10
and 20 and you can go to the patreon you
can support it 5 10 20. I think you mean
no one's gonna pay for the 50 000 one
you know I'm waiting
did you see that did you yeah yeah yeah
that's good I I would I would here's
here's what I would do because I had
this question someone said what would
you do if someone actually paid you the
fifty thousand dollars and you wouldn't
do your show I'm like no our show would
still be on I just wouldn't be talking
yeah I would like I would like maybe I'd
give Gabe or someone else a part of the
money to come on and just talk and then
I wouldn't be saying anything so as long
as I shut up yeah I believe I mean
that's what it is if you pay fifty
thousand dollars Pony will talk yeah
right doesn't mean the show won't go on
and if you pay 50 000 a month hell I'll
stay shutting up I'll just pay someone
else to do the talking for me with fifty
thousand dollars I think I can find
someone to do the talking for me for a
little while so yes at the 50 000 is a
little bit at a people's range I think
that was the the joke yeah yeah um but
they want some different tiers so I'm
coming everyone I never know what
someone will pay that's true that's true
so I might I might do some polls over
the weekend so everyone out there that's
interested um to know about uh my
patreon just go to the Tony michaels.com
you can go over there and you can see
and I'll have some polls up and you can
see some of the posts on there I put
public post and I put uh supporter post
only but you can go over there I'll put
the polls public so you can tell me what
you think so I might do some polls this
weekend on different things that I could
do in different tiers if that's what you
want to have also happy birthday uh to
Kalyn again and then um I want to thank
the moderators also
um for being here and more importantly
you in the audience you are the best
audience
in the world yeah
I truly believe that and you know what
while I'm at it I might as well pimp the
merch Go to stories Jenny michaels.com
store.donymichaels.com this is the Ron
DeSantis can go himself we brought
up Rhonda especially true this past
couple weeks it is that scumbag
him and him and the Banning books I
don't even know how that fascist Hitler
not only the Banning books but saying
I'm gonna now reject any legislation
that would come after gas stoves when in
reality only eight percent of the State
of Florida uses gas stoves 92 percent I
would almost like that I would almost
bit Bottom Dollar Bottom Dollar if you
go look at that eight percent and if you
could go around and find them and pull
them of exactly their ideology I almost
bet
that it would be more liberals use gas
stoves than oh probably yeah almost bet
yeah almost I would almost bet bet my
YouTube channel on it maybe while we're
at it why don't you subscribe to that
YouTube channel that I'm betting on
um we're trying to get to 20 000
subscribe that subscribe button right
and download every single episode every
single weekday Monday through Friday we
do it live we do it live on YouTube
twitch Twitter and Facebook speaking of
YouTube uh there is a new channel that
are it's a Content creators channel the
up wire go to upwire.com you can find
that YouTube channel go subscribe there
there's a bunch of creators that are
putting content over there on the up bar
so
um we're over there posting our show
live so do that as well and if you're on
Facebook help follow us on Facebook why
not Mark Zuckerberg won't be too goddamn
mad about that everybody I hope you have
a safe weekend now be be safe come back
Monday same time same place noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific right here on the
interwebs
Surf's Up
leading to the Tony Michaels podcast in
your face commentary of current events
and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime you've been listening to the
Tony Michaels podcast in your face
commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon